meantime this weekend president trump is
turning up the pressure as he calls for
larger direct payments to americans in a
tweet he says
why would politicians not want to give
people two thousand dollars rather than
only six hundred dollars
it wasn't our fault it was china give
our people that
money we bring in talk radio host the
voice of indianapolis tony katz good to
see you my friend
uh where's all this money coming from
i i think it's still coming from china i
mean that's of course the question
where is all this money coming from and
what is the need
for all this money or who's causing the
need president's not wrong that this
virus comes from china but a lot of this
need comes from the fact that we have
governors and mayors who have shut down
businesses
in a haphazard non-scientific way and
it's still
causing disaster and six hundred dollars
when you see
all the places that they had money
earmarked for
really does insult people to their core
all across the country from the coast
to the heart of of the nation that this
isn't something that we should look at
and say oh yeah that sounds normal
that you're sending billions of dollars
uh to the egyptian military there's
nothing wrong with possibly working with
the egyptian military there's something
very wrong with doing that
when you've got americans who are told
they can't go to work and feed their
families
that's the fundamental issue
back in college i had a great professor
who talked about the production seesaw
and television there's what you can do
and what you want to do and when the two
get too far out of whack
uh things start to fall apart is that
what we're at here
congress took six months to negotiate
this the idea they're gonna renegotiate
american foreign aid
in the next five days really
oh no no congress did not take six
months to negotiate this
it took finally an election to happen
for nancy pelosi to be willing to have
the conversation
because she didn't want to give any type
of political win to president trump
if anybody's having an issue really
understanding the story
remember that we could have helped
americans months ago
but nancy pelosi refused and did it
there's no one okay
there's one church there's more later
refused there may be the political facts
on the ground and then there is the
optics
if the president is putting democrat
republicans in the senate in the
position of saying no which it seems as
though many of them are which is why
and for that matter republicans in the
house because it did not pass by
unanimous consent
on christmas eve that's a tricky place
for republicans isn't it
well the idea that president trump has
put republicans in a tricky spot before
isn't
anything new okay hold on let's get to
understanding let's get to this point
i'm saying
what a tricky speaking of a tricky place
you've got jordan
republicans on the trail in georgia take
a listen to kelly lefler
what david perdue and i have been doing
is fighting to make sure that every
single georgian can live the american
dream
like president trump we're business
people we're political outsiders
we went to washington to work for you
and i've committed to you i will never
bring washington to georgia i am taking
georgia
to washington you know what's
interesting her whole stump speech
never once did she talk about the
coveted relief or the stimulus bill
you know if you take a look at the
person who ran against her for that
special election doug collins
he also voted for the relief and there
has been nobody who's been a more vocal
proponent and supporter
of president trump than doug collins
georgians of course are paying
attention to this and of course there's
a conversation about what this does to
the runoff
election but the idea that this one
story is playing big in that election or
will determine that election
that's not true even if you look at the
atlanta journal constitution there's
only one real story about this it's not
even a headline story
wsb a radio station that i fill in on
from time to time 95.5 fm
they're not talking about this story
this is much more a beltway concoction
than it is real life
well it becomes about real life as you
pointed out when you're talking about
the people who need the six hundred
dollar checks or the
two thousand dollar checks many need so
much more unemployment insurance runs
out
at the end of this week as does the
eviction moratorium tony excellent
points good to see as always you
understand when i say i'm up against a
heartbreak it's true that i
am but i think there's going to be more
to talk about in the coming weeks we'll
see you soon my friend thank you
happy new year